we begin right now with chief White
House correspondent John Roberts it's
been traveling with the president good
morning John Rec good morning to you
what we're witnessing unfold here in
Singapore could be truly historic what
happens here over the next few days
could begin the process to eliminate one
of the greatest threats facing the world
or it could go nowhere
president Trump touched down in
Singapore pronouncing that he is feeling
good about the prospects of his meeting
with Kim jong-un
but as he departed the g77 in Quebec
president Trump acknowledged he was
flying into the unknown it's unknown
territory in the truest sense but I
really feel confident I feel that Kim
jong-un wants to do something great for
his people and he has that opportunity
and he won't have that opportunity again
it's never going to be there again Kim
jong-un had arrived earlier in the day
traveling farther than he ever has as
North Korea's leader courtesy of China's
national airline Kim later meeting with
the summit hosts Singapore's prime
minister Lee Seon loon president Trump
will meet with loon today the red line
at Tuesday's talks the complete
irreversible and verifiable dismantling
of North Korea's nuclear program
president Trump has stated repeatedly
that he will walk away if he doesn't see
progress and that he will know quickly
where their progress is possible how
long will it take to figure out whether
or not they're serious I said maybe in
the first minute you know the way they
say that you know if you're gonna like
somebody in the first five seconds you
ever hear that one well I think that
very quickly I'll know whether or not
something good is going to happen
back home calls for the president to
bring whatever deal he cuts with Kim did
Congress Massachusetts senator Edie
Markey who never asked for President
Obama's Iran deal to be ratified says
Congress should have it say I think it
would be wise for the president to come
to Congress to ensure that there is a
ratification of any agreement which does
take place between the North Koreans and
the United States but president Trump
had already preempted Markey saying on
Friday he would make any agreement with
North Korea a treaty
unlike the Iran deal I would only do a
deal if I get it through Congress I
wouldn't do like Obama did as he arrives
in Singapore for perhaps the most
important meeting of his presidency
President Trump leaves behind grumbling
allies at the g7 after President Trump
departed Quebec Canada's Prime Minister
ripped him up one side and down the
other on trade it's kind of insulting
and I highlighted that it was not
helping in our renegotiation of NAFTA
that prompted retaliation from President
Trump who tweeted he has instructed our
US reps not to endorse the summit
communique and criticized Trudeau as
dishonest and weak chief economic
advisor Larry Kudlow said Trudeau
stabbed the president in the back
double-crossed him Trudeau decided to
attack the president that's the key
point and yes you know if you attack
this president he's gonna fight back
Kudlow added there is no room for a show
of weakness before this important summit
on Tuesday and here's the way it will
unfold the president's first meeting
will occur at nine o'clock in the
morning Singapore time it will be a
one-on-one with kim jeong-hoon just the
two leaders plus their interpreters and
expanded bilateral meeting will happen
later on in the day president Trump said
yesterday that he hopes it's an
opportunity for them to finally meet
face to face
adding he also hopes they like each
other
there's always that John Roberts just
around the block here in Singapore John
thanks